soon the arrowverse will be missing its
namesake show as the CW's arrow will end
after eight seasons with a final 10
episode run the other arrow verse shows
will continue least for now
but here's why the flagship show is
really ending ratings seem to have
played a role in arrows cancellation but
they probably weren't the definitive
factor viewership numbers have dropped
for a few years and in 2017 the show was
shifted to Thursday in the hopes that it
would get some castoffs from
supernaturals superior ratings
unfortunately it instead suffered a 14%
ratings decline viewership dropped off
again in 2018 and which point the
question on most fans Minds may have
been why it wasn't already cancelled a
couple of days after the announcement
that arrow would end Screen Rant
reported that while the show continued
to lose viewers in 2019 things weren't
completely bleak in fact the site
reported that statistics they received
from an analytics firm showed arrow as
the second most successful of CW's for
air / series at the time of its
cancellation coming only behind the
flash so while flagging ratings may have
contributed to the end one would assume
that Supergirl and legends of tomorrow
would also be cut if that were the only
factor the term superhero fatigue has
been thrown around for a few years now
with people understandably wondering
exactly when the public is going to grow
tired of caped crusaders
arrow may be the victim of a CW specific
version of this phenomenon along with
all the arrow burst shows the network
also airs Black Lightning and will soon
air bat woman and there continued to be
rumblings about Superman getting his own
CW entry the arrow verse was already
crowded and it's getting more crowded
every year one of the factors of the
decision to end arrow may be that there
simply isn't enough room for it the
timing of the cancellation makes this
possibility more likely considering bat
woman's pending arrival of all the air /
series arrow is usually the grittiest
and bat woman may need to inherit that
title in order to thrive another
possible reason for arrows finale is
that it's a perfect time to end it the
arrow verse is known for its annual
crossover events the 2018 edition
entitled Elseworlds
featured a seemingly godlike being
called the monitor who said he was
preparing earth 1 for something
cataclysmic
this world will be doing
then the crossover ended with the tease
for the following year's event which
will be called crisis on Infinite Earths
that's also the name of a classic 1985
comics story that might be the most
important DC Comics crossover of all
time
it changed the publishers entire
financial landscape bringing together
disparate narratives and completely
wiping out others the event was also
noteworthy for some prominent character
Jones which is where arrow may come in
since the final season will only be ten
episodes the finale will probably air
close to the crossover considering the
timing it seems like a good bet that
whatever narrative choices are being
made to wrap up the story of Oliver
Queen possibly including a heroic death
they'll have a whole lot to do with the
events of crisis perhaps we shouldn't be
asking why arrow is ending but instead
why it's even lasted this long
Oliver Queen has walked over the same
ground again and again literally and
figuratively
there have been hours and hours of
flashbacks to the island of Lian Yu
where he was stranded meanwhile in the
present he and his team arrow buddies
have gone back to the island so often
that it's a little confusing why they
don't just build a summer home there
there have also been countless times
when characters have died and then
somehow come back or sworn off the crime
fighting game only to quickly return to
it but worse than the repetitive plot
points is the ongoing unconvincing
struggle with Oliver's darker self his
inner struggle seems to say that he is
both Hannibal Lecter and the only person
who can solve the world's problems it's
a dead Horace that the arrow creative
team finally needs to stop feeding
according to the show stars Stephen
Amell the biggest determining factor for
ending arrow was Green Arrow himself
shortly after the announcement that the
show's eighth season would be his last
Amell posted a facebook video to let
fans know what had happened he revealed
that he'd approached producer greg
berlanti at the end of the sixth season
expressing his wish for season 7 to be
his last I've always been a fan of of
television shows that not only don't
overstay their welcome but and in a
manner that really packs a punch
fittingly considering the character has
grown to be much more of a family man
over the years Amell told viewers that
the changes in his
own life behind the camera greatly
informed his desire for arrow to
conclude like the character he plays
he's become a husband and father himself
and it's understandably been a
significant change in his life
flashbacks have been one of arrows
hallmarks since its first season but the
show switched things up starting in
season seven as the premiere ended with
a flash-forward set 20 years in the
future with Oliver's grown son William
meeting an older Roy Harper over the
course of the season a story has been
unfolding in the flash-forwards about a
time when vigilante has become a dirty
word by going forward arrow has painted
itself into a corner unless there's some
sort of time-traveling salvation
everyone watching the show knows how the
future looks for its characters it's not
good as one review for cinema blend puts
it the flash-forwards potentially took
away any reason to keep watching from
that perspective it's best for arrow to
wrap up quickly before things getting
worse
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]